à
aujourd'hui on est le 7 septembre c'est
l'ouverture du procès de julian assange
il risque l'extradition vers les états
unis
pour avoir divulgué des crimes de guerre
en irak et en afghanistan entre haute et
avoir soutenu ce ne donne quand il a
dévoilé que tout le monde était sur
écoutes de la nsa et là il risque 75 ans
de prison s'il est extradé vers les
états unis
d'ailleurs il est australien donc on
comprend pas bien pourquoi
ils peuvent demander l'extradition d'un
une personne qui est pas ça qui est pas
américaine a bien été
[Musique]
temps plein d'amour panneaux seront
assemblés parce que la déclaration n'a
pas été faite même si c'est un
rassemblement et pas l'unanimité dans le
wagon de la cij aménorrhée cours
[Musique]
4 et moi je veux les publier sur leurs
gros canons du savoir
lever à l'autre est mineure
[Musique]